Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. Today, we are taking a look at
some of the new features that are just
recently been released with Teleport version eight.
I'm your host today, David Flanagan. I don't
remember my name correctly this time, and you
may know me from across the Internet as
Rawkode.
As you might be able to tell, I'm
in an an entirely new space doing a
livestream on a five g router.
So let's see how this goes.
Today, I am very lucky to be joined
by Steven Martin once again from the Teleport
team. Hey, man. How's it going?
Oh, good. Doing really well.
Awesome. Well, welcome back. Yeah. It's it's gonna
be fun. It's always nice to take a
look at some of the the things that
are happening with a Teleport. It's such a
a cool product that I literally use every
single week. So it's always a always good
to sit down with someone over there and
and cover some of the new shiny stuff.
For anyone who didn't see the last episode,
could you maybe give us a small introduction
to who you are?
Sure. Yeah. And I'm I'm Steven Martin, solution
engineering
manager here at Teleport.
Just coming up on my two years.
And for folks that aren't familiar,
you know, Teleport is a open source access
plane and certificate authority,
you know, for your infrastructure.
So, essentially,
you know, we make it a very secure
way, passwordless approach to accessing your resources, whether
that's SSH machines,
web apps, Kubernetes,
databases,
and now with eight point o, Windows desktops.
Nice. Awesome.
So here's a question that I never gave
you upfront, and I'm gonna lump on you
now and and just see. Like, you you
use Teleport a lot. Right? Would that be
a fair assumption?
What's what's your what's your favorite feature?
I
think the part of it is the is
the tunnel,
the fact that I can have a machine
available.
I I run some some of my own,
you know, personal sites,
and I wanna get access to it. But
I'm I am concerned about open ports,
you know, and people being able to attack
those ports,
especially ones that I don't wanna expose all
the time. So the fact that I can
SSH into something or even provide other access,
you know, without opening in a port
because,
you know, yes, you could try to try
to do some firewalling and locking down,
but that gets hard, you know. Whereas this
case, you know, you you can really restrict
that more.
Yeah. Definitely. It's a great feature for sure.
I think it reminds us the the ability
the capabilities to pair
either through the web GUI or the command
line client. Think those those are cool. I've
been able to debug something in real time
with some colleagues, especially at our new remote
first world. I think it's it's fantastic.
So what's new in Teleport eight?
Yeah. This is we we consider this, you
know, one of our largest
releases,
version eight.
First, the the one of the largest ones
that people have probably heard about is our
Windows desktop access.
Now we're not providing, you know, an RDP
protocol.
That's one of the one of the ways
we're we're taking this is that we think
the
you know, and I'll be stepping through that
shortly, you know, exactly how that works and
example of it.
But using our web console, you know, folks
will be able to open up desktop interaction
to their current, you know, Windows machines.
Typically, you know, those are your your server
types,
like, 20 Windows 22
22 data center
and others even even back to 2012.
In addition, we are providing things like WebAuthn,
you know, if you wanted to use your
watch or in my case, I'm gonna use
the the Touch ID.
Others like, you know, being able to auto
find
r RDS machines,
whereas previously, you had to specifically
poke at it, or point at exactly.
Another is
the
ability to dynamically add apps and databases.
I'll I'll be showing a Grafano example today
where you'll be able to directly
say, okay. I want to deploy this application.
Here's its tag, and then an existing agent
will that has registered itself to run those
tags will automatically run it. So that's a
way of getting away from, you know, worrying
about, oh, I deployed. Did I set the
right YAML on that machine? But now you
can just say deploy. Here's your tag, and
it'll you know, kind of like Kubernetes automatically,
you know, run on a particular agent.
Awesome. Well, it sounds like you've got some
amazing things to show us in the demo.
So we will get to that in just
just a moment.
We have a a comment from Av and
Ash, which I'm gonna pop back up again
just saying that session recording has to be
everybody's favorite feature. I just I just Oh,
yeah. No. Yeah.
Yeah. No. Yeah. I definitely take that for
granted.
I think it's it's something where, you know,
you wanna you wanna review, you know, what
happened. And I look at that as, you
know, it's great for auditing, but as a
you know, often if you're a developer or
someone who's looking back on, okay, what did
I exactly run? Because, you know, control r
doesn't find everything right.
You know, I wanna look back at what
did I run, what order did I do
it, were there any errors, and you can
see it from that. Yeah. Yeah. Definitely.
Alright. Well, shall we get your screen shared?
Hop off the demo, and I'll do my
best to throw loads of questions at you
as we go through. Please.
Yep. There you go. You are now live.
Take it away. Great. Thank you. So there's
a there's a bit of a space theme
going. I'm on moon,
teleportdemo.com,
and, you'll see some Apollos and Hercules,
as we go. So first off, let let's
start, yeah, let's start with the Windows example.
So these are some
particular two domains I have available. So that's
one of the things is that you can
hook on to multiple active directory domains.
It'll automatically bring in,
you know, the particular
tags, you know, for those machines.
I I went ahead and connected,
via desktop access here. You can see these
running concurrently.
So I'm on, you know, one of the
Apollo machines, and I'm also on, one of
the Hercules. And it's just like regular, you
know, RDP if you're used to interacting through
that.
But the major difference is I came in
passwordlessly,
so I did not have to, you know,
provide a password password here, type it in,
or save it locally on my machine, you
know, which is what most of the RDP,
you know, clients do is it gives you
that option. But, you know, how secure is
that?
You know, versus in our case and I'll
and I'll show in a minute, you know,
how we're connecting in there.
You know, user themselves do not have do
not have to supply
a password. But you do supply,
you know, case of the roles.
You would say,
you know, okay. Here's here's the labels you're
allowed to connect to and then what users,
it takes in my email. So that's how
it comes in with Steven. So you can
see I'm connecting with my particular username, Steven,
that's allowed to go in there.
Awesome. Very cool.
Yep.
And, right now, we have, you know, we
have the initial web and you you notice
it's labeled preview
in that a couple of the major features
coming, you know, will be the session recording,
will be things like clipboard. You notice it
is in it is in the the web
browser.
And, again, that's because we don't think that
providing the RDP protocol directly is the most
secure way. We think that providing it through
the web console does provide you that added
protection that, you know, the proxy is sitting
in front of it. It's it's verifying your
access to the machine.
It's then using a virtual smart card approach,
and that's the way that it's it's securely
identifying you through to the active directory,
and it's it's it's maintaining that for you
so that, again, to the user, it's it's
all seamless.
Yeah. It's very cool. I I I don't
think I've ever worked for a company that
doesn't have one or more random selection of
Windows servers just floating about in the infrastructure,
and, like, the access management to it was
always a bit
a bit wild west y, to be honest.
And so this is, like this is actually
bringing these things under almost proper fleet management,
at least from an access point of view,
which I think is really, really cool.
Yeah. One one thing to point out is
in terms of the labeling. So some of
these, you know, some of these are are
just pulled directly,
but then you can give additional labeling,
in terms of you know, you'll notice here
I have the one environment production.
So the this is not the same as
some of these other tags as well as
the domain. So if we take a look
at,
in terms of,
you know, the configuration here. So this this
is the this is where I've set up,
the Windows desktop service from from the machine
I'm connecting to.
I'm saying this is my domain controller,
the domain that's actually connected to Apollo,
the user.
You can also set it up to use
another more generic user, like Teleport Service.
That's actually in our documentation.
But then this is part of how you
can do more host labeling. So in this
case, I'm saying if the name matches this,
any any of the machines that have this
this name,
label them domain. So this is an additional
label I'm putting on. And then in case
of, like, Hercules, I wanted to add in
a production one. So I'm looking for that
prod name and add it in. So that's
where you could give that. I don't want
you going to all machines, but I'm gonna
say your user can see, you know, particular
labeled machines.
Alright. Does this have any requirements on, like,
a minimum Windows version? Does it run on
all Windows since 10? Or
Pre window well, we Windows Server '20 twelve,
and up. Now
Windows ten eleven could work. I'd say most
of our clients are gonna be running the
Windows servers.
And you do need to be in a
domain so that so the, you know, you
know, these are part of an active directory
domain. Alright. Okay. So it's not I can't
expose my personal Windows machine over that quite
yet, but maybe in the future. Yeah. No.
No. Exactly. Yeah. Right. I mean, again, it's
we're we're really focused on making sure it's
the most secure connection,
and active directory allows us to do that
virtual smart card approach. So it's patchless.
You could you could just put up an
RDP. You know, you could just pass through
RDP protocol, but then you're just typically gonna
be saying, okay. Put in your username and
password and go. Yeah.
But, again, we wanted to make sure it
was the most secure way.
Awesome. Very cool. I like that. Yeah. Yeah.
I'd say the other one, which, one of
the other cool features is around our about
ports.
So you probably have noticed in your configuration,
the number sometimes you have a number of
ports open, right, to allow access to Teleport.
And with our,
you know, latest version, you can limit that
to a single port, like four four three.
So if you take a look at
and, this is getting a little nerdy.
I
can take a look at a configuration
of Teleport through here,
and this is telling me all the ports
that are available. So you notice they all
have a common four four three. So it's
saying, this is my public address. This is
what I'm going through the browser. This is
my SSH. This is my Kubernetes,
you know, database, all 443.
Now I have another server,
enterprise,
more of a Star Trek theme. You
notice there's different ports.
So I in this case, I'm running it
off. You and you have the you have
the option of using either.
There are some times where you may wanna
run that, but, you know, this really simplifies
it going to a single port.
Because, you know, as as you might run
into or we run into some of our
enterprise clients, you know, it can be difficult
for them to open up, you know, a
number of ports like that, whether for users
or for the agents,
to be able to provide that connectivity.
So that's really a a big thing to
to make it, you know, easier for security,
as well as just configuring your environment so
that I don't have to worry about, you
know, different ports in the load balancers or
things. I can just use a single one.
Yeah. The less ports I have to open
up to the world or even in a
private even a private network, the better.
Yeah. I get that.
Yep. Yeah. And and you can always use
this this
URL web web API slash find to look
at, you know, what is the configuration for
the server, what's the server version, and and
the different ports.
So that's that's usually a good way that
I when I'm working with a new client
or someone just checking out the OSS, like,
if they're having a trouble with the port,
hey. What's your configuration? And they can do
this.
Nice.
Cool.
Now one of the other and I mentioned
earlier was about our
support for web auth in,
and I hope I'm saying it right. I
was it's like
web web auth in. I'm sure everyone's maybe
maybe in in The UK, you say it
a little differently, but, the n.
But, essentially, that's providing another you know, previously,
we'd supported, like, the Google auth type,
as well as YubiKey,
and this takes it to another level, you
know, with our support of things like touch
ID or using your watch and able to,
authentic
you know, additionally,
authenticate a user.
Now in this case, what I've done is
I've said for a particular nodes,
if they're labeled prod,
then you do need to use that. And
we can check your you know, I have
a prod access role.
You'll see this is requiring MFA true.
Yep.
And then on your individual deployment,
you can decide,
are you gonna support multiple? So a person
could have Google auth. They could have YubiKey
and web auth. Or you may say, well,
we're only gonna do you could say only
a particular one.
So it's up to you if you want
to allow multiple or only or only allow
a single on your machine.
Then in this case, you know, so I'm
gonna go ahead and log in there. It's
gonna say, need to verify.
And I just got this Mac, so I'm
using this lovely,
fingerprint thing.
Thought that was pretty cool.
And now now I'm in the machine. Now
if I go to another machine,
like in this case, a
dev one, I don't need to because it
doesn't have that require on. But I'm saying
for particular labeled machines,
then you you will have to do that.
Yeah.
Okay. So we yeah. You can save for
these labels or these individual nodes that you
require that that second factor before we actually
give you access to. Does can
you use Touch ID to log in to
the Teleport server too,
or is that just Yes.
For for local users, you could. Now in
in if you're using a single sign on,
we would assume that would take over for
the authentication part of it.
But if you're if you're using local users
only, yes, you you can you can certainly
use that. That's sweet. Nice. Yep.
Yeah. We definitely recommend that if you're if
you want to have,
even if you're using OSS, let's say let's
say you're using GitHub as your SSO,
well, maybe you want a backup
local admin user in case, you know, as
we've seen, sometimes things go down
in the last week or so,
you know, then you could have an MFA
on that admin user. We'd certainly recommend that.
And that that is the default to have
an MFA on.
Yes. So you're sure there's touch ID there,
but that's gonna work with anything that supports
web auth in, really. Right? Yes. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Exactly. So
this web As long as,
Yeah. As long as the, yeah, the the
browser supports whatever web browser you're using, then
then you should be good. In terms of
how you control
it, so in terms of my account setting,
can say I have two. So this is
my
touch ID, and then I also have a
Yubi registered.
So the YubiKey, I can use
in my
desktop interaction,
you know, whereas the the touch ID, can
use with my Safari browser.
Cool.
I like that feature too. It's just one
of those quality of life improvements. Right? It
just enables that things available at touch ID
or Windows Hello or anything else like that.
It just and rather than getting your phone
out and looking for Authy or Google Authenticator
and all that stuff, you know, with the
biometric approaches. Password. What is my password? Copy,
paste, show, reveal.
You know, as as you're out on and
as you probably run into your if you're
out on the train or out somewhere, like,
I don't really wanna be showing
people my codes or passwords, but I like,
you know, having a touch ID is is
very convenient. Yeah. Well, I I have a
an Apple Watch, and the first thing I'll
be doing now in my Teleport cluster is
seeing if I can get that all hooked
up so that I can access my Oh.
My machines with just touching my watch, which
will be nice.
Yep.
Now
I am I am running this in AWS.
So definitely one of the things I wanted
to touch is on our additional AWS features.
And you can see here I've I've a
number of
accounts available. So from a single Teleport
instance,
you can and I'm doing you can do
this from the
where you're deploying it or from an agent
that's running in AWS,
then you can act you can allow access
to multiple roles in different accounts.
So you can see here I have one
account here, and this is actually our main
solution engineer account,
and then I have others. So that gives
you that ability, you know, and a lot
of us, especially if you're running enterprise, you
will have multiple
AWS accounts.
So then from here, can launch right into
it.
So I can see my servers.
I can go to r d RDS.
And then and then it it is restricted
to,
you know, what that role is allowed access.
So I've gone in as SAM power user,
which power being that user has fair amount
of privileges.
Or by default, you'd probably wanna give them
read only, and then then they can access
request to get more access.
K.
That that was almost too much magic in
one go for me there because
it feels as if you just logged in
beforehand
and it's magically worked. But that's actually launched
you an AWS console session, logged you in
as a user that was listed on Teleport,
and then that's what you're I mean, it
was just so fast.
Let's do a different AWS account.
Yeah. Yeah. I think I
probably have to
check.
Didn't mean to put you on the spot
there. No. No. No problem. Yeah. No. I
I think I didn't add a role for
this user,
but that's that's part of how you would
just just to highlight how you configure it.
You know? So you'd add in different roles
here. Mhmm. And then you would say what
account they're allowed to see. So that's why
it's not showing those others because that account
wasn't identified.
Yeah. But if you wanna add another one,
yeah, you could do that that way.
Yeah. It's just,
you know, we're looking at the list of
AWS accounts. You click launch, and right away,
I'm staring at the AWS console. It was
just, you know, it worked too well at
that point where I'm I'm skeptical though. I'm
like, really? Did that just happen?
So Yep. Yeah. No. It's it's it's very
fast. One of the things we've noticed is
that while there are way and I I
mentioned about that power user, you know, we
have seen where
requesting additional access can be complicated in some
of the SSOs.
So this gives you that ability to do
that
often more quickly.
Now you also have this in local,
you know, from the command line.
So you can see I'm logged in that
same user,
you know, particular access.
I can take a look at the apps.
And I already I already logged in. Let
me let me show you. Let me log
out of that one so I can show
you the
so if I log in directly to
access, it's gonna get a little mad at
me because what do you log in as?
Okay.
So, okay, before you hit return on this
Mhmm. Or or maybe even another terminal, can
you run AWS
s three l s or something? That's just
something that would, I guess, fail. Sure.
So this should say unauthenticated,
I would imagine.
Yeah. Okay. Yep. Yeah. No. And this this
is a very new brand a brand new
machine for me. And we and we've gone
in our case, we, you know if I
wanted to do that because we use Okta,
I would have to log in through Okta,
get get the, you know, temporary tokens, and
then copy and paste those here.
So that's a little bit a little bit
of longer process for me.
But, yeah, I'd say I don't I don't
have the access yet.
If I
see,
I am still getting used to this Mac
world.
So I'm I'm logging in as that same
that same access you saw me clicking.
Yeah.
So now I'm logged in. Yeah. That
you can do that one.
No. That's the button. So I use that
command, t s h eight AWS.
Now the other the other thing which which
I wanted to show, particularly with this console
access,
is
the concept of using the auto join.
So one of our features here, if you
go into our documentation about,
you know, joining nodes.
So often in in you've seen this where
and let me you know, if I wanna
add a new new machine, I might do
tokens
add
type equals node.
So then I get I get this particular
token. I can copy copy and paste it
and use it on machine.
Well, rather than worrying about token distribution,
do I use SSM? Do I use,
you know, Vault or something? You know, we
we we saw the best way to do
that was to,
you know, have the concept of, you know,
auto joining.
Now it will this will allow you to
install Teleport,
and I've gone ahead and done that in
AMI machine
where it's it's already built in. It uses
the EC token
e e EC two token.
The machine itself that's running has permission to
look up that machine and verify it.
You can see here this is the policy
it's setting,
and and then this is example of the
token that I've I've already configured, you know,
what roles are allowed, SSH, apps, things of
that nature.
You also set in here,
okay. Well, how how long until this when
the server starts is it still allowed to
join?
Because it's not unlimited. You can't just install
Teleport, use token, and then go.
This is meant to be used for when
any server first starts up. And then you
also are setting well, okay. Well, what accounts
are are allowed to join and what from
what regions? So you can restrict where those
machines are coming from. So it's not just
open.
Yeah. So you have a a fair amount
of control here.
K.
Yep. So in this case, I have, a
set of AMI machines. The one I wanna
use is example node three. It's it's a
Amazon Linux two,
with a built in Teleport
installer already there.
Go ahead and do t two micro, whatever
is your favorite.
As part of this, I wanted to you
I wanted to be able to pull out,
some of the tags,
when it runs. So it pulls it pulls
in tags, and it's both gonna use that
in terms of how it connects
to Teleport
as well as just informational things. So that's
a useful feature if you can you can
say, oh, pull pull in whatever tags are
being set on your your EC two.
And I am I don't need SSH, so
I'm taking it out.
Now the way I'm I'm telling it to
connect and not necessarily the way you have
to, but I'm saying this is your auth
service. So I don't need a token, but
I'm saying this is what I want you
to connect to.
I'm gonna name you
dev
three.
You're in environment dev
and then group dev. When I was setting
this up, was like, environment groups, those are
sometimes different.
Let's do that.
So we're pretty good to go.
Alright. Let me you can click the button
now, I'm gonna try and
rephrase what I think you're doing just to
make sure I understand that what what was
actually happening here. So you've got an AMI
image, an Amazon machine image that you're spending
up, and you've added some tags to it
through the UI. Now you've assigned an IAM
role to this machine so that it can
query its own tags.
Also,
this AMI
is shipping with Teleport,
which because
it's in this account with the right role
is auto going to auto join your Teleport
cluster
and be automatically approved and be available in
the UI.
Is that
close? Pretty close. The the one thing is
this doesn't need a role itself to join.
It's the server itself that has the role
that can verify that machine.
So you don't you don't need to you
don't need to come with a role as
the node. It rather, it's the server itself
has the role, so it's able to describe
instances. Otherwise, it couldn't confirm,
what is what is that machine, where is
it coming from. Okay. So yeah. So there's
nothing special about the machines themselves, although other
than that you've configured it with a tag
to tell it where the the cluster server
is. That's it. Yeah. I I I didn't
have to do that. It was just my
my preference. Yeah. Okay.
K. It looks like I didn't run that.
What is what I thought it was O,
E C 2.
Oh, yeah.
Good catch.
I have to stay at that for another
forty five minutes before I noticed.
Well, just wanted to so I'm using so
I'm using our AWS access here to to
verify has it started up yet. I can
see it has started.
Everything we saw before,
it's in US East 1 D,
and it is running.
So then if we go back, here it
is.
And as part as part of this configuration,
I'm using our our PAM.
I installed Teleport. I use our PAM integration
so they can auto create the user. So
Steven isn't on this machine, but it'll auto
automatically create it when it comes in.
I also I also allow this you know,
the user to get pseudo rights, know, just
like EC two, but I'm it doesn't have
to come in as EC two. And then
this this is what I was mentioning about,
you know, getting tags. So Yep. This is
pulling in
the
metadata intent, which you don't need a role
for that, but you do need it for
this if you wanna pull out a group
and environment, and then I have the PAM
on. And here here's that token part. So
there's no, you know, long token needed anymore.
You just say I'm joining by e c
2 token. It's gonna see I'm coming from
US West 1 in the account, and then
it's gonna let it's going to allow it
to join.
Okay. I I I got two questions then.
So let's assuming I wanna be able to
replicate this in my own AWS infrastructure. Anyone
watching does. Like,
what's what's special about this AMI or what
do they need to do themselves to be
able to get this kind of workflow without
using the, you know, your demo AMI?
Yep. I'd say they would they would have
the AMI.
They or I'm sorry. They would start with
a machine. They would want to install
Teleport
and at least have
the token
configuration set up. So you're saying I'm using
a token and the auth service.
I I had this Teleport YAML generated, but
you don't you wouldn't have to. You could
just set up the Teleport YAML,
and have that ready to go, have the
Teleport service installed and enabled,
and then it'll start and then use this
configuration.
The the biggest thing is making sure that
your Teleport
auth service is on a EC two that
has this permission that is allowed to describe
those instances. Otherwise, it can't confirm
that, you know, as you set here,
what account is it, what region is it,
and then verifying that it's allowed to join.
Okay. So because that allow list there takes
multiple accounts, like, I can actually have a
single Teleport
that looks after or has access to my
instances across multiple AWS account?
Yep.
Very cool.
I like that. I guess my my next
question is how do I get this on
every other cloud now? Is that is that
Teleport nine? Do I have to wait a
little longer?
Well, kind of like the console part where,
you know, a a large amount of our
clients are AWS.
So we we have initially released console and
CLI for AWS.
You know, we'll see one one of our
ads,
and I don't have that database running on
this one, but we did just add our
one of our first Azure
features of database.
So we're supporting their Postgres and MySQL,
which you know, so that so we are
expanding into, you know, GCP
and Azure. I'd say right now, the Console
and CLI are AWS only, but we we
could see about adding them in there. A
lot of it is Yeah. Yeah, how how
well do they integrate from an API standpoint.
Some of them make it more awkward than
others,
but, you know, we're we're continuing to look
at it. AWS needs us the most. I
mean, I don't know how many times I've
had to bang my head against access delegation
for AWS. You know, Azure and GCP are
lucky. Like, generally, those companies are using g
Suite or maybe even Outlook or also c
six five, and it's all integrated really nicely.
But AWS is just this big sore jaggy
thumb of authentication.
How do get people access to this within
my organization?
At least I I've always found it notoriously
difficult. So I
like this feature. I think it's a whole
lot.
Yep. Yeah. And we try to make these
docs I mean, part of why I'm showing
them is make them as explicit as possible.
Also, on the AWS console one,
which I wrote part of that, so yell
at me.
Not
but this steps you through really low really
low level with, like, giving you read only
access example and a power user example.
One of the trickier parts I found is
that it says power user.
I had to expand that,
because the it it doesn't give you IAM
rights.
You can you can I can do an
e c two, but then I couldn't in
in this case, I couldn't actually assign an
IAM role to my e c two, which
seems kind of strange? But you have to
have a specific IAM permission to do that
or even if I wanted to change IAM
roles.
So what they might call power user, and
this is a default role in AWS,
may not always mean what you think.
So I'd say that's the only extra thing
is making sure you you're clear what these
roles are doing
Yep. And that they don't always cover every
part of AWS that you expect.
Awesome.
And we have a question from the audience,
which I knew was gonna come up eventually,
and I'm sure you've heard this a billion
times.
But Kevin is asking, any chance we can
have SAML or YDC in the open open
source version so that we don't have to
use GitHub?
Well,
yeah. I mean, that that's
one of our particular enterprise features,
probably one of the largest that people decide
to go enterprise.
I'd say most of our clients
who are using SAML or ADC, you know,
are already in
a company.
We don't see quite as many of our
open source. Maybe there are more than I
expect.
Like, if they're using, Keycloak,
you you could use that.
But, you know, right now, we see that
as a way of us providing value in
enterprise, whether you're using our hosted service or
the on prem.
Now, you know, in in some cases, like
with our RBAC, you know, we release that
to open source. Previously, that was an enterprise
feature.
So, you know, we are we are always
evaluating that. I I there's no plans that
I know of to release that that way.
But we are looking at, you know, still
increasing the GitHub feature, making that, you know,
even better.
So, you know, we we we do we
definitely don't do want OSS to be,
fully usable in in a deployment. You know,
we're not trying to say you get 90%
in the last 10% you have to pay
for.
But, you know, for now, we we do
think it's better to keep that as enterprise.
Yeah. I'm always very thankful that the GitHub
one is available for me because I I
I use it in all of my Teleport
instances.
What I would say to you, Kevin, is
I know Kevin is in the Discord server.
So jump into the Teleport channel and tell
us what your use case is, and I'll
share that with Steven and the Teleport team.
And maybe there's maybe something will happen in
the longer run. But I do like the
GitHub SSO. It works well. Yep. Yep. Oh,
no. We we definitely appreciate feedback on that
and other features. It helps us to understand
what the community is doing and and making
sure it's definitely functional for them.
Yeah.
Okay. Alright.
That's that's a lot of features in a
release. I've gotta say that that that
but you could you could just have done
the desktop of Windows access, so that would
have been already a huge release, but that's
to add on all this other stuff as
well.
Well, just say, I I I've a lot
of my
when I when I was a consultant,
often, we were we were deploying
to Linux servers,
but our our development and some of our
even our staging until we got to final
release was Windows.
Or we or we might rely on active
directory for
maintaining our single sign on. Like, well, we
have to get to that machine.
And it was, you know, often a single
admin user or,
it it could be difficult to,
issue issue passwords that, weren't like your typical
one.
So we definitely see that that expands
our functionality and, you know, a lot of
what we think of our our, you know,
customer,
you know, usage
that that it's that a lot of people
are using both.
And nowadays, it gets kinda tricky about, you
know, we don't have Windows phones much, but
many people are using surfaces. Many people are
using Windows servers for various various reasons.
Alright. Awesome.
Suresh, I do see your comment.
I'm not sure I fully understand. So if
you wanna type in a bit more detail,
please feel free. I will read out the
question for you, Steven, but Okay. I think
we might I think we might need some
more on that. But Suresh is asking, do
we have any monitoring tool which can pull
container and server metrics on dashboards for Teleport?
So I'm not sure if Suresh is asking
if Teleport exposes, like, Prometheus endpoint or anything
like that or if it's gonna prevent access
to other Prometheus endpoints, but I'll let you
if you wanna try it now, so let
go for it.
I'd say I mean, Teleport provides its own
Prometheus metrics.
It it does not
it's not offering a general set of metrics.
So we would expect you to use another
tool,
like Prometheus.
You can definitely get access to those,
through Teleport.
So it's not it's not just
but I would say it itself is not
meant as a a monitoring tool,
you know, for your particular set of services
or servers.
Yeah.
That makes sense. Yeah. Alright. Harish, if you
wanna add any more details, if we didn't
answer that question for you, just jump back
into the comments and we'll do our best.
Is there anything else, Steven, you wanna you
wanna show us? Yeah. A couple couple quick
things. One, and I and I think this
is a little bit related to what that
gentleman was asking in terms of,
you know well, when you do wanna let's
say you did wanna deploy,
a particular,
you know, either analytics or monitoring system. So
this is a case of,
you know, I have a Grafana
configuration,
and I want to deploy it on a
machine that will take my Grafana.
So
you can in this case, we can take
a quick look at you know, I I
have a Teleport agent running here,
and I've said,
okay.
This is an app service. I'm not specifically
defining
my app services,
but I'm saying you can,
I will take any applications that have this
this, particular set of tags? So it's in
development environment, and it's the Grafana app. So
then when I'm ready, I can just say,
t cuddle create.
And then that's deployed,
directly available,
and I can launch straight into it.
So just a few seconds, I was able
to deploy
a particular web application
right on right on an agent that's running.
So that's a big jump from have as
we I talked a little bit earlier, having
to have that YAML all defined, all perfect,
all set,
and, you know, oh, where do I wanna
run it? You know, I have to have
that in the right place. You know, as
long in this case, I can say, well,
I'm gonna deploy an agent. I I may
not even want it running all the time.
You know, I may wanna deploy this and
then take it and then take it back
down. So I I can actually
just remove that.
Now it's gone.
So is
that is the is the magic effect again,
Steven? You're you're Yes. You're confusing me. So
we're we don't have to run
any more agents? Is that what you're is
that did everything else apply? You're still the
agent. So I am definitely running an agent
here. Okay. This this dev one, this machine,
I deployed it specifically
because I wanted it to be
an agent. Oh, okay. I want yeah. So
in this case, I'm saying I want I'm
allowing resources,
web applications that fit this labeling.
Oh, okay. Okay.
Yeah. Got it. Yeah. If I try if
I try to yeah. Exact no. That's that's
an important point. If I try to deploy
this with environment
prod,
I would have to have an agent that
accepts those labels.
And then it it it wouldn't find a
home if that's if that's not if that's
not set.
So it's meant to be, yes, that I
I'm saying I want this particular
deployment.
And Okay. You know, it'll it allows you
allows you to do that. Similar similar to
Kubernetes, like, you have the the taints or
tolerations, right, of saying, you know, what's what's
allowed to be to run here.
Yeah. You've given us the ability now to
kind of schedule
these app services and point them to the
correct agents to expose them. Previously,
I was always it was a very manual
process. I was having to make sure I
set up the agents in the regard, please,
and and Yeah. This is this is much
nicer. Again, one of those quality of life
things that just makes it all a bit
easier to get started.
So Yep. I mean, it took me a
minute to work at what was actually happening
here, but I like it though. I got
it.
Yeah. Cool.
The one I want and and kinda a
little bit similar to the
in terms of auto finding
is the databases. So you notice I have
a mix here of names. I have some
that are look a little you probably noticed
are a little more manual types where I'm
I'm I have a name, I have a
tier,
and then here, I have ones that are
more expanded. They have an account ID, engine
version,
and then and then others here.
So in terms of this database agent
I can take a look here.
I've I've configured this database service. So I've
said, you will find any database service or,
like, RDS
that has a type of RDS
and this tag environment dev.
And if we take a look at
back on our RDS,
Maybe?
Yeah. US
East One. Don't go down on me again.
So
I have this.
Is that the one I want?
That's fine. So
I've tagged this as environment dev. So it
will only bring back,
those
specific,
databases with that tag, And then you'd you
can allow users to have that.
Now, again, just like the
allowing machines to come in, my agent running
needs permission to find these databases.
And once it has that permission,
and it's also able to
control
your its access,
that's one of our important
security considerations is that it can auto find
them and add them,
but you also want to
limit what it can do. So in this
case, I'm saying, okay.
You can
get your role. You can change your role.
You can modify it.
But I'm gonna put a boundary on you.
I'm gonna say, you're only able to do
this.
You can connect, but you can't do more
than that.
And that's an important thing we we strongly
recommend people using this feature do is set
those permission boundaries so that a machine itself
can change its permissions to say, well, I'm
gonna add, you know, a database connection here,
but, you know, we're not gonna let you
then,
add in some other service or things. You
know, the machine can only set, you know,
these particular changes for it. So so it's
dynamic,
but it's not able to do more than
that than what you're limiting to, the the
permission boundary.
Nice.
Yeah. Very cool.
Yep.
And then this also also leads into that
that,
you know, port thing where I can,
you know, provide that access
for user.
So I can log in to,
you know,
and then what if I if I wanna
connect, I I can set up a proxy
to it
that allows me to,
you know, keep that single
single port.
Nope.
I think I think I meant to do
one.
Yep.
There you go.
But in this case, I'm I'm going through
the local proxy,
and then I'm connecting through to through that
single Teleport four four three. So this way,
I don't have to expose, like, the three
zero three six or another port,
for the user to go through. But I
can I can use this this proxy approach?
And that that again allows us to use
that single port approach which simplifies things.
Yeah. 100%.
Couldn't agree with that, Mark.
Alright.
Their ask is Quite a lot. Yeah.
That's it's it's it's a big release. I
mean, I just don't understand how Teleport maintains
this velocity. I feel like it was just
a little while ago. We were talking about
all the new features with Teleport seven and
the new database access stuff, and then Teleport
eight sneaks up on me, and there's all
this other new stuff now. And I I
love the balance of, like, here's some new
shiny features, but also we're always making improvements
to that quality of life. Like, I think
half the stuff we've seen today is just
making things simpler and easier for Teleport users,
which is fantastic.
Yeah. And people are welcome to join our
Slack.
You know, there's also get GitHub discussions that
we have in our repository.
So both are great great places
to have that dialogue,
you know, so it we really encourage people
to to try things out. You know, most
of the features
besides that SAML one we talked about, you
know, those are all those are open available
in open sas open OSS.
We're already seeing some dialogue in terms of
desktop access and things. So definitely encourage people
to try those out and let us know
any questions.
Yeah. I I I think I say this
to everyone, but just there's no there's no
excuses for not having a Teleport in your
setup these days. It's just you get so
much value from having it there
and and convention,
and security is hard. Like, why would you
make it harder and not have something like
Teleport there to take away some of that
burden?
Yeah.
Thank you for taking time out of your
day, for joining us, preparing those demos, and
walking us through it. Really, really cool additions
to Teleport.
And then, hopefully, we can have you back
again for Teleport nine, which based on your
velocity, will soon be in about three weeks.
Maybe maybe Ben and I will join. We'll
we'll join together.
Awesome. Alright,
David. Thank you so much for having us.
Just, you know, please please, visit goteleport.com.
We hope you try it out. Let us
know any feedback, good and bad.
And as always, I I really enjoy dialoguing
with you here directly,
David, or or anywhere else. It's fantastic to
work with you.
Alright. Awesome. Well, it was a pleasure, and
well done on all those demos. They all
worked. There were no full paths other than
potentially AWS going down, but I think we
managed to stay away from that.
Have a great day, Steven. It was a
pleasure, and I'll catch you again soon. Yep.
Bye. Yep. Happy holidays. Bye.
Live.